it's Valentine's season and you're
probably looking for some amazing games
to play with your significant other here
in this season of romance so here's what
you shouldn't be playing picking who
gets to be who and Disney infinity sucks
wanna shoot ice beams at everyone like
Elsa too bad you're olaf the snowman you
can't be Mickey Mouse because she
insists on using her limited edition
Kingdom Hearts King Mickey outfit power
disc so you get stuck with shitty Donald
Duck han Solo and Chewbacca guess what
you're Chewbacca if you character dies
you can just swap to another which is a
great excuse for your partner to not
cover you in combat it's fine honey you
can just switch to someone else but I
don't want to switch to someone else I
wanted to be a han Solo why don't you
give me your [ __ ] Han Solo and then
we can continue the game speaking of
Disney things best left out of your
relationship star wars battlefront is a
terrible relationship building game in
the event that one of you is super bad
shooters there's nothing more annoying
than trying to get Emperor Palpatine out
of your rebel base while your s 0 is
running in circles trying to get a
better view of him as he lightning
fingers to death all of your teammates
around you you shouldn't play this game
with someone you have to sleep next to
at night because battlefront is all
about that team cohesion and tension
mounts when someone just isn't pulling
their weight I need you to shoot that
honey I'm trying dear we'll try harder
sweetheart well go [ __ ] yourself darling
i should say any MOBA ever because
nothing kills the mood like an action
realtime strategy online battle arena
you didn't acquit man on magic sticks or
whatever and then you died and your
partner's all super pissed that you
weren't there to back them up in mid
when the other teams jungler came out
and summon avoid that blew everyone up
there's too many things that can go
wrong and you will always always find a
way to blame each other when she's not
there to set up a ward for him or he
doesn't have a courier or whatever the
tensions run high and I could hear it on
Team chat and I imagine that nobody got
any that night haven't you learned by
now that these games are designed
specifically to destroy your
relationships it's one thing if your
partner's better than you at quickly
spitting an analog stick and it's
another when the game gives you a
thousand stars for no logical reason
it's all luck so when one of you is
having bad roles and the other is not
tensions do get a little high well maybe
next time pick toad sweetheart and
you'll get all the stars def
hbu killer so I'm all in for a little
video game hanky panky but what if your
significant other is not what if she
walks in the room while you're
vigorously banging someone on a unicorn
what if she doesn't understand the
nuances of this game it makes a big deal
out of it or what if he's uncomfortable
that you're having sex with fake people
and asked you to maybe maybe not go
after it with such gusto how about you
reconsider that relationship instead I
am saving you all some trouble by
heading you off at the pass with this
one you make some pretty big decisions
but a lot of it is just sexting over a
walkie-talkie also you might learn a few
things about your partner that maybe you
don't like fire watches your alone time
Firewatch is a game about you and your
decisions there's some things I want you
to know honey there's some things I
don't this is one of them please leave
your best girl is Rhys a his is yukiko
it is not going to work out actually any
long JRPG at all is probably the worst
idea I mean you're sitting there
spending hours grinding and not the fun
kind while she sits there and waits for
you to get to the next major story beat
if you want to play story game together
that's fine but when leveling up your
character comes first you're not at all
when you lose a battle your feelings as
a caretaker are bared to the world how
you treat and raise your Pokemon is a
direct reflection of how you would treat
creatures in your care in the real world
mostly babies whenever you lose your
sweetie in a Pokemon match they're
secretly thinking about how terrible you
will be at raising children so what if
Bulbasaur learned cut it wasn't enough
to take down its enemy therefore your
offspring will be ill-equipped to deal
with anything in the real world the more
Pokemon ulit fainted a match the more
likely it is your children will get into
accidents because you're inadequate
parenting and your significant other
they noticed aka that game where you get
to pick each other up and throw them
into lava instead of working together to
do what you're actually supposed to do
do this to your girlfriend one too many
times and you'll be on the couch after
the game finishes
it's supposed to be co-op when your
partner forges ahead and you're left
trapped in a bubble you're left floating
waiting for your partner to rescue you
and when they're too busy to pop you
well it's a pretty good indication of
how they really feel about spending time
with you especially if they're the ones
who picked Super Mario 3d Land to play
together in the first place those are
just a few of the games we suggest you
pass by as you're browsing those
gamestop shelves this weekend if you
have any words of warning of your own
leave them in the comments below
Oh